[Musica]
fatti scartare non scartarli da solo uno
dei migliori insegnamenti che mia nonna
ha dato a noi nipoti mia nonna nonna
Teresa classe 1916 grado di istruzione
la quinta elementare non è andata alle
medie perché altrimenti i ragazzi la
guardavano grado di curiosità spaziale
il suo gruccio è serenato troppo presto
perché computer stavano aprendo una
nuova era e io me la stavo perdendo qua
era il su 80o compleanno
1996 E coincide come con il periodo in
cui io e il mio compagno Emilio Billi di
vita e di lavoro avevamo iniziato la
nostra avventura un'avventura che è
iniziata con una domanda Secondo te è
possibile costruire un supercomputer con
hardware standard prima di rispondere
inquadriamo il periodo era il 1996
venivano messi sul mercato i primi
Pentium la memoria di un PC era 4 mega
un hard disk 80 100 me i computer più
evoluti avevano il cdrom l'USB non
esisteva il sistema operativo stava
passando da Windows 3.11 a Windows 95 e
internet iniziava a comparire in alcune
case contratti molto costosi non
esistevano gli smartphone non esistevano
i tablet non esisteva il WiFi i siti
disponibili alta vista e poco altro
Google non era ancora nato social
network e app fantascienza il gettone
del telefono le 200 lire e la scheda
telefonica erano i mezzi di
comunicazione per noi ragazzi
Considerate che uno smartphone Oggi ha
una potenza di calcolo di circa 500
volte quello di un pc di all'ora e cosa
fai quando ti viene fatta una domanda di
questo simile nel
1996 Innanzitutto cerchi di capire che
cos'è un supercomputer A che cosa serve
come hai fatto e quindi studi Ma prima
di andare avanti capiamo che cos'è un
super computer a che cosa serviva a cosa
serve e perché realizzarne uno con
hardware standard un supercomputer non è
un computer grosso è per definizione un
computer costruito con la massima
potenza tecnologica disponibile al
momento della sua realizzazione è la
formula 1 dei computer senza compromessi
il massimo che si possa avere
tecnologicamente parlando L'inventore
del supercomputer è semo Roger cray la
definizione di supercomputer è stata
data da Gordon Bell per chi non lo sa
Gordon Bell è il padre dei sistemi
operativi moderni e ancora oggi Esiste
un premio l'equivalente del Nobel in
informatica che si chiama appunto Gold
Bell Price Allora il supercomputer
grazie alla sua potenza di calcolo è in
grado di svolgere in maniera efficiente
un grandissimo numero di operazioni per
secondo flatting Point Operation per
second flops Siamo partiti da megaflow e
siamo arrivati oggi a petaflops ed
exaflops tradotto siamo passati da
milioni di operazioni al secondo a
milioni di miliardi di operazioni al
secondo questa potenza di calcolo però a
cosa serve Serve per fare cose super nel
senso di al di sopra di qualsiasi altra
macchina i supercomputer Giocano un
ruolo chiave nella ricerca scientifica
nella modellizzazione di modelli e di
fenomeni complessi come cambiamento
climatico per le malattie e molto molto
altro ancora capito A grande linea Cos'è
un supercomputer e a cosa serve torniamo
alla domanda da cui tutto è partito e
dopo 10 anni di studi ricerche
esperimenti e prototipi la risposta è
stata Sì è possibile costruire un
supercomputer con un hardware standard
Questo è il risultato della nostra
ricerca Era il 2005 il nostro
supercomputer aveva la potenza di 96
miliardi di operazioni al secondo per
farvi capire meglio l'importanza della
potenza di calcolo dove Da dove siamo
partiti e dove siamo arrivati e verso
Dove stiamo andando Guardate queste
figure la prima figura figura
rappresenta la crescita della potenza di
calcolo degli anni nel 95 vedete che era
circa di 10 alla alla 10 quindi
operazione al secondo adesso siamo circa
10 alla 16 operazioni al secondo vuol
dire 10 milioni di miliardi di
operazioni al secondo adesso paragoniamo
questo a più sofisticato supercomputer
esistente in natura il nostro cervello
il nostro cervello ha una Penza di
calcolo di 10 al 18 operazioni al
secondo con un consumo di circa 20 V
siamo efficienti e voi starete pensando
supercomputer potenza di calcolo Ci
saranno state grosse aziende che li
realizzavano E perché pensare di
realizzarne uno con hardware standard e
a che serve e poi in quegli anni con
quelle tecnologie il motivo per noi era
ovvio per dare accesso alla potenza di
calcolo anche ai piccoli gruppi ricerca
che altrimenti sarebbero stati limitati
nel raggiungere i risultati Considerate
che un cray costava circa 18 miliardi di
lire 9 milioni di euro perché è fatto
con pezzi hardware Stas specializzati e
noi volevamo realizzare la stessa cosa
però senza scendere a compromessi però
usando hardware standard Cat inage
tecnologico ma non fatto su misura
questo avrebbe abbattuti i costi ma
voleva dire studiare capire quali pezzi
usare come usarli come metterli insieme
Che problemi risolvere e come render
assolutamente efficienti abbiamo
iniziato quindi a studiare a informarci
a leggere tutto il materiale disponibile
e a cercare di materiale aggiornati
Emilio scrisse a Daniel illis che è il
padre della connection Machine un super
computer che gli mandò copia della sua
tesi cioè gliela spedì per posta non in
formato elettronico ricordate che Sian
nel 96 ma entusiasmo a parte quando
abbiamo iniziato questa avventura
pensavamo che prima o poi ci saremmo
fermati anche perché la paura di
sbagliare e di non essere all'altezza
Era comunque una costante ma non
sapevamo che la curiosità lo studio la
voglia di di capire come funzionano le
cose per riuscire ad anticipare
sarebbero state così pervasive da
spingerci ogni volta e ogni giorno a
tirar fuori il meglio di noi devo
aggiungere che oltre allo studio
dell'impegno c'è stata tanta incoscienza
emigo una volta ha detto Certo che noi
siamo strani chiunque Prima di buttarsi
Controlla di aver il paracadute e che
questo funzioni noi ci siamo buttati E
quando ci siamo accorti di aver bisogno
del paracadute ce lo siamo costruiti in
volo ed è stato vero in America dicono
knowle is Power e questo è terribilmente
vero noi stiamo continuando a studiare
sia per lavoro ma anche soprattutto per
passione personale e soprattutto in
questo periodo di enorme cambiamento
rivoluzione Questo è fondamentale e non
è mai stato così vero in questi anni
l'innovazione e la tecnologia hanno
accelerato come mostra questo grafico
l'uomo è portato a pensare
all'innovazione che funzioni in maniera
lineare in realtà l'innovazione è
esponenziale e oggi il suo impatto è
esplosivo come rappresenta la riga rossa
la curva Rossa soprattutto questo grazie
all'avvento dell'intelligenza
artificiale e questo è diventato
terribilmente evidente una cosa
importante l'intelligenza artificiale
non è informatica ma è matematica
applicata Ecco perché servono i
supercomputer non stiamo programmando un
dispositivo che se Schiaccio un tasto
Allora si apre la cartella sono reti
neur che apprendono dai dati dal
contesto e non vengono programmate
quindi non sono pilotate dall'uomo mai
come in questo periodo la discriminante
lo studio e la conoscenza è evidente che
in questa rivoluzione non sia accaduta
in un attimo C GPT non è nata in 6 mesi
così dal nulla se vi dicessi che almeno
dal 2014 ci stavano lavorando e noi dove
siamo arrivati a mezzo exaflow di
Potenza L'ultimo nostro supercomputer ha
la potenza di calcolo di mezzo cervello
in un armadio Rec e stiamo continuando a
studiare e a f
ricerca per accendere il nostro primo
supercomputer Abbiamo impiegato quasi 10
anni per arrivare alla potenza di
calcolo di un cervello Abbiamo impiegato
altri 15 anni e mezzo e mezzo ci sono
stati due ragazzi che guidati dalla
passione dall'entusiasmo sono cresciuti
maturati e hanno costruito un'azienda
sono consulenti per grandi aziende
vincono premi e sono qui a parlare al
tedx a volo dire la verità tutto questo
è successo ma noi non ce ne siamo mai
accorti ce ne siamo accorti dopo degli
anni ho visto varie versioni di me da
quella della foto impacciata che voleva
fare il medico a quella con il
cacciavite in mano che assembla in due
ore un cluster o che fai meeting qu le
grosse aziende a quella che ritira premi
e soprattutto a quella che si mette in
discussione ogni giorno in tutto questo
io ho sempre cercato di essere me stessa
per essere libera non mi sono mai fatta
influenzare da quello che dice la gente
risha fman insegna questo ti porta a
tirar fuori il meglio di te anche se ha
un costo e pensando ai momenti in cui
mia mamma mi diceva che non condivideva
quello che stavo facendo e come lo stavo
faccendo aggiungendo tra il compiaciuto
e rassegnato con un sorriso ma sei tu
credo che in quel sorriso ci sia il mio
più grande successo intimo e personale e
la più grande spinta nel continuare io
vi auguro di riuscire a seguire la
vostra strada realizzandoli come persone
padroni del vostro tempo e delle vostre
decisioni e fa paura uscire dagli schemi
ma è più grosso atto d'amore che potete
fare verso voi stessi e nel rispetto
della vita perché come diceva nonna
Teresa non vi dovete scartare
[Applauso]
[Musica]
mai